Okay.
Today
the coming of mass affluence,
uh,
to the advanced economies,
principally the economies of the west.
Uh,
Jennifer,
speaking of informal property rights,
I thought you owned a chair right up there.
That's just kidding.
I'm going to take it in three chunks.
We're going to look at big picture,
causal explanations for the rise of mass affluence and for explanations first
for its rise and second for its rise,
beginning in western Europe and North America.
A second I'm going to uh,
re re reintroduced the joint stock corporation into that conversation.
And finally we're going to look at the phenomenon of mass affluence and the
advertising culture,
uh,
mid 20th century America.
Then on Wednesday we're going to,
we're going to descend to details.
And the challenge for you in preparing for Wednesday is to imagine a country and
imagine that you somehow have been granted a fund amounting to 5% of its gross
domestic product.
And with that 5%,
uh,
you want to make whatever changes you can imagine will increase the overall
wealth of that country,
uh,
as much as possible.
So it's a pragmatic question.
It has a,
it has a causal side to it,
but ultimately it's pragmatic and it is not one size fits all.
That is,
you've got to know something about the country to know something about what
needs doing.
5% of the GDP in Ghana will be spent,
will be wisely spent very differently than 5% of the GDP in Bolivia or Mexico or
Norway.
Okay.
So the first of the three topics is capitalist takeoff.
Uh,
the portrait of this corpulent and obvious obviously effluent gent is Sir
Richard Arkwright who was the creator of the most efficient early textile
machinery and who,
unlike many others about whom Clark talks actually profited very handsomely from
that work,
uh,
by takeoff in the West.
And this goes back to the first day of class and by Wednesday we'll go back
again to um,
gapminder.org and look at the bubbles moving through space.
Uh,
this still photographs,
so to speak,
covers,
uh,
a longer time horizon,
a 500 year time horizon,
and it shows a,
an abrupt northward movement in GDP per capita in the u s uh,
lagging a bit in Japan,
a lagging further in China,
India and Indonesia.
Uh,
and if we just throw all the countries in the world in a pot,
uh,
we get a picture that looks something like this,
where,
uh,
gross GDP is in blue,
a population in green and the one divided by the other end goal.
And
what we're interested in,
uh,
from here to the end of term really is in understanding what lies behind these
curves.
And in thinking about,
uh,
from a given country's point of view or from a given class of people in a given
country's point of view,
uh,
how can we,
how can we increase the rate at which things get better?
Now,
before I go further,
some of you are thinking green thoughts
at wave at me.
If you're thinking green thoughts and wondering whether it's really a good idea
to have so many people with so much money in their pockets.
Some of you Sasha,
tell us we've got to,
we've got a mic here.
Thanks Morgan.
Um,
I think basically the root of all environmental problems if you care about the
natural environment is that there are too many people,
so you have more people who can consume more.
The simple thing to think is that that's bad news for,
for the earth.
Okay.
So you would like to kill off a portion of the world's population?
Yes.
Okay.
That's very straight forward.
Good Clear Mba thinking.
It's so,
and given a constant world population,
if,
if we had a,
would you prefer that that population on average be a little less affluent than
it than it is or then I seem that I seem to want it to be,
um,
I'm not sure that it's that straightforward because if people,
societies don't have the means to advanced technology,
even though consumption does go up,
you have cleaner technologies that would be developed with,
with greater economic prosperity.
So I'm,
I'm not as clear on that one.
Not as clear that you would acknowledge that as hundreds of millions of people
living in places like China and India come into,
uh,
income enough to have a family car or even to that,
there's a challenge there.
Certainly.
Yeah.
Okay.
So let's keep the natural environment in the background as we talk about this.
But let's for the moment focus on economics and let's start with a curve like
this.
The rent,
the,
the curve shows low income to the left high and come to the right and the
frequency of each income straight him is indicated vertically.
And the red curve is a fairly typical market economy.
Income distribution with a truncated tail on the left and an elongated tail on
the right,
uh,
with the mean income being much higher than the median because it is pulled to
the right by the very high incomes.
Uh,
if this chart were drawn to scale,
that right hand tail would probably be even more he long dated,
but wondrously thin,
uh,
out to the,
out to the right.
Well,
the phenomenon of takeoff is the upward shift in that distribution.
It may change shape a little,
but it's not mainly that it's changing shape.
It's that its mean is drifting upward and to the right.
Okay.
And if we think about two distributions,
a two or three generations removed from one another in a given society,
let's say the United States,
1920 and the United States today,
uh,
it will often be the case that the difference is so dramatic that the material
condition of people living in the top 10th,
then we'll be about like the top half today.
And You
keep that up for 10 generations or so.
And you have something like this where the top decile in,
uh,
let's say 1800,
is living in material conditions that would be equivalent to perhaps the ninth
decile today,
not the very bottom,
but people living relatively near the bottom.
Uh,
and this is particularly true if you take into account not just,
not just income,
uh,
but what it is that income can buy in the way of medical care.
Uh,
comfort,
comfort in lodging,
a quality of diet and so forth.
So there's an enormous explosive change in the background here.
And that change is our subject.
Now,
how you feel about that change is more complicated and we often hear that money
doesn't buy happiness.
Uh,
the people who say that,
uh,
have evidence of a kind,
none of them volunteer to become poor
and there is something that money buys a that people want and we'll return to
that from time to time.
But imagine now that there just think about an economy with two people in it.
Uh,
[inaudible] uh,
income or wealth is measured vertically,
visa as measured horizontally.
And you're Mister H.
Uh,
which of these two outcomes would you prefer?
On
my one way of thinking,
if you're maximizing your own income,
you'd like to be there.
If on the other hand,
what you're doing is staying ahead of the Joneses,
uh,
you'd like to be there.
Uh,
more generally if you're just trying to maximize your own household income,
you will have indifference curves like these horizontal ones and just seek to
climb as high as possible and you'll be perfectly content if others climate the
same rate or even a higher rate.
On the other hand,
you may be calculating the ratio of your household to other households that you
choose to compare yourself with.
And the indifference curves will then become rays from the origin like that and
you will be trying to swing your position,
uh,
from bottom right to upper left.
So one function is just maximize one variable and the other is maximize the
ratio of two variables.
And most people
are a,
tend to mix these two things.
And the,
their contentment with their,
uh,
material position is Hartley relative and partly absolute absolute here,
relative there.
And if you,
if you,
uh,
think about,
the employees of affirm,
the way they're compensated,
uh,
is,
raises both concerns.
Suppose everybody in a law firm is making between 150 and $200,000.
And along comes Jim Alexander,
ace corporate lawyer,
never.
I know I'm abusing you.
Never.
And all right,
Leslie Huff,
a corporate lawyer,
and,
uh,
we really need her and we've got to pay or $800,000,
and we make the offer and she takes it.
Uh,
there will be a,
if this fact becomes public within the firm,
which is quite likely a,
everybody else will in some measure feel impoverished by it.
She's making four times what I'm making.
Surely she's not four times better than me.
Right?
And so the,
the relative and the absolute are always at play.
Now,
let's look through Clark's explanations.
And I spent almost all of yesterday reviewing Clark and he's kind of all over
the place.
There's some of everything in this book,
but let's pick out some of his,
uh,
main explanations for economic takeoff and for the fact that,
the takeoff occurred first and most dramatically in western countries.
And,
uh,
among Western countries.
First in,
uh,
the United Kingdom and his,
there's a recurring theme.
It's in,
uh,
the beginning,
the middle,
and the end of the book,
uh,
about his speculative interpretation of wills from,
England in,
uh,
late medieval and early modern and,
and,
and right into modern times.
And the phenomenon he found it finds is a fountain of well born children who
cannot replicate their parents' place in society.
And the empirics on this are pretty strong that,
uh,
that well to do.
Families by and large had more than two surviving children,
uh,
reach a more than two children reaching adults.
Uh,
and indeed the survival rate among to do children was,
uh,
quite a lot higher than the survival rate among other children.
And if you read all the way to the end of the book,
you discover that if you compare this with,
uh,
Asian societies such as Japan and China,
the effect is stronger,
uh,
in England.
Okay.
And from this,
he had deuces,
um,
several consequences of the most obvious of which is that many of these well
born children will be downward mobiles.
They will marry beneath their class,
they will take up occupations or roles,
uh,
beneath their parents class.
Uh,
and
Clark Clark is,
um,
he's trying to say two things at once.
One is that the culture,
the universalization of culture from the top could in some measure be promoted
by this downward mobility that,
uh,
children,
raised with high expectations and,
uh,
and,
upbringing,
uh,
make be cultural carriers,
which would infuse lower economic strata with a,
a more energetic,
more performance oriented,
uh,
outlook for that.
There's no evidence in the story.
It's just a speculation.
Uh,
and the other speculation for which there is also no specific evidence,
uh,
is a Darwinian genetics story,
in which,
and here Clark is,
uh,
you know,
this is dangerous territory in the way of,
uh,
politics.
Uh,
he seems to believe that the genes carried at the top of the,
of the income curve,
uh,
may be better genes than those elsewhere in the income curve.
And that the downward force,
downward mobility of progeny from that top level gene pool,
uh,
might upgrade the whole society in a genetic sense.
MMM.
Anybody want to comment on that thought?
Yes.
Genetically speaking,
it's just sort of silly because treats don't pass directly.
You weren't a clone of your parents or even just the 50,
50 combo in terms of caring skills downward though.
I mean that makes a lot of sense.
If you're well educated and you bring that down,
you might educate your children now values,
et cetera.
Okay.
That's my,
that's precisely my own view.
But does anybody want to defend Clark here?
Yup.
It could
more of a bell curve situation if you know,
if you know what I mean,
that
people,
uh,
on the higher end of the e the income ladder have over time,
um,
been privy to better situations and better selection pressures leading to the
evolution of skills like,
I dunno,
analytical thinking,
intelligence skills that are necessary for the professions that are
characteristic of the hierarchy.
MMM.
What's that?
Let's have a vote here.
How many people think it's likely that there is some validity to,
let's start with the cultural story and then go to the genetic story.
How many people find the cultural story broadly plausible.
Okay.
And,
and the opposite implausible.
Okay.
And how many find the genetic story broadly?
Plausible.
Okay.
Fewer but a substantial number.
And how many find it implausible.
Okay.
I have no idea.
And Clark provides not one shred of evidence with which we could test this.
Um,
my own guests is that a few hundred years is a pretty short time for carrying
out the law.
That kind of selection process he has in mind.
Uh,
it's also the case that the association between,
uh,
parental,
um,
uh,
let's call it Iq.
The twin studies actually do confirm this that were identical twins are born to
Ms Mr and Mrs. Smith and raised by Mr and Mrs. Jones in Iq and several other
variables.
The association between the identicals will be greater than between them and the
siblings belonging to the new family.
So genetics is not wholly out of the picture.
Uh,
on the other hand,
from a pragmatic point of view,
which is where we're going with all this,
uh,
the idea of,
well,
what was eugenics?
Does anybody have any of you in a history course?
Picked up eugenics?
Anyone
back back with a mic here?
It's an idea that in some form has existed since ancient times,
but really picked up in the late 19th century.
And then especially under the Third Reich where it was essentially believe that
people at the top tended to have better genes or in the case of the Third Reich
is specific racial group and therefore you want to maximize the number of people
with certain desirable traits.
Were we producing and minimize the ability of people undesirable traits to
reproduce,
resulting in a better or stronger or smarter in the case of the Nazis race?
That's the jest of it.
Um,
I had had the though part of it,
which was most influential had to do with,
I'm trying to prevent,
um,
uh,
people who were mentally retarded from reproducing.
And uh,
and a lot of that happened,
um,
the vulgar prejudices that lay behind much of it.
It was much of,
it was conducted by something called the Vineland Institute located near
Princeton,
New Jersey.
No guilt by association there.
Uh,
and the Vinyl and institute published data showing that all the immigrant groups
streaming into the u s in the early 20th century,
uh,
were inferior to wasps mentally.
And they were very tough on the Jews.
The Jews are just not bright at all.
And they did this by administering English language questionnaires to immigrants
just after they got,
uh,
the pragmatics of culture or something that's a lot easier to deal with and
which fits more readily into the humanistic framework that we share,
uh,
after that,
after the,
the fountain,
which really doesn't fit in any of his categories.
Clark has three broad categories.
One is exogenous growth theories,
exogenous meaning economic growth caused by something that is,
um,
that has its origins outside the market economy.
And,
uh,
one of these ideas,
which I think he's right about a,
he doesn't run with it very far,
but the emergence of the nation state system,
the rule of law,
um,
the existence of a well formalized property rights,
all that stuff,
uh,
is pretty powerful.
I,
and the Western world was the initial focal point of a Westphalian nation state
system.
Uh,
Clark is at pains to show that that by itself isn't enough of an explanation.
And in general,
no one should expect one story to explain the evolution of capitalist wealth.
This is way too complex.
A story way too complex,
a phenomenon for a simple theories to carry the day.
A special case of that would be wealth maximizing law as illustrated a,
we could go in again versus rich,
uh,
or in a US versus Cosby or any of hundreds of,
legal precedents.
Uh,
Clark also,
um,
briefly towards the end of the book takes up the work of a guy named Kenneth
Pomerantz and Pomerantz has a book called the great divergence,
which asks the question,
why did the,
well,
he begins with a proposition that from a social and economic point of view,
China and Japan both looked a lot like Europe,
uh,
in about 1800.
And there's lots to quibble within that generalization,
but it's not crazy.
And that he says,
well,
you're takes off,
uh,
well over a century ahead of those Asian countries.
And,
uh,
he wants to know why.
And His thesis is,
it has to do with natural resources.
And in particular that large population centers like the cities of England,
we're located close to large energy resources such as the coal mining areas of
the Midlands in the United Kingdom.
Uh,
and also,
uh,
have almost equal importance for Pomerantz,
access to vast agricultural land
in the form of North America.
And that about 1800 was the time when the exploitation of the largely empty
continent in the United States,
uh,
was feeding resources into Western Europe.
And there's some plausibility in those ideas.
Yeah.
Uh,
then Clark talks about multiple equilibrium theories and the idea here is think
of time passing that way and standard of living or productivity going this way.
And the idea is that,
uh,
a country could climb this small hill and get stuck here and then there'd be
some exogenous shock,
some huge event outside the economic system,
which would allow it to pass from that equilibrium to a new equilibrium on top
of the Taller Hill.
And
the world's demographic transition
is such a story and not a crazy story at all.
The notion that the falling death rate,
uh,
created by better public health,
probably more than any single factor by clean water,
uh,
an elementary vaccinations,
but clean water probably above all else.
Um,
and the eventual adjustment of the birth rate to that so that you go from high
birth rate,
high death rate,
short lives to low birth rate,
low death rate,
long lives.
Uh,
that by itself is a,
is I think without question,
a powerful element
in the story wherever a nation state society,
uh,
has got gone from poor to rich [inaudible]
then the endogenous growth theories.
And these are,
I this,
the idea here is that something happens inside the economy that creates a
dynamic change and that dynamic change,
uh,
lead,
to,
uh,
mass affluence.
And I think there's a lot in this idea,
um,
which of course is not.
Clarke's Clark is merely cataloguing other people's ideas.
And,
uh,
does anybody recognize either of these two handsome gentlemen?
Yeah,
I'd prefer the haircut on the left.
Uh,
this is Joseph Schumpeter.
and this is Faa Hayak and each of them
had an idea about market societies.
That has to be central to our thinking.
Uh,
in Schumpeter's case,
it was creative destruction.
And I'm told by the teaching fellows that most of you knew that quite well on
the midterm.
Um,
and creative destruction,
uh,
is,
is a way of reshuffling the deck economically at short intervals.
So that looking back
at this story,
so that sitting still on this hill is difficult for a,
for any given from,
and arguably impossible for society at large once you're into a capitalist
market economy.
Uh,
one way to diagram that is
this diagram,
we have the capital invested in a given kind of product or production,
uh,
rising from left to right,
and the productivity of that capital rising from a bottom to top and each of
these curves is a,
is a production function,
uh,
representing a technology and a way of organizing people and handling
information.
And the idea would be that change occurs in the sequence one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six here where there's a process of climbing to the right as we go to more
capital intensive production,
more capital per worker.
Uh,
and then while a tall is doing that,
uh,
Jennifer is saying,
well,
no,
we should reorganize this entirely.
We should use a different technology,
a different method of attracting investments,
a different method of compensating employees and she shifts
to the lower end of three.
And then that gets carried to here and then a similar shift,
uh,
to the blue production function and an up that.
And so it kind of Zig Zag story of change where uh,
people compete not within one production function but between production
functions and a chaotic pattern of creative destruction occurs.
What makes it creative is that it is ultimately an upward movement in
productivity.
And a version of that story is in Clark.
Uh,
but he doesn't really think,
uh,
in the dynamic way that champagne,
her and Hayak and others do.
High Act story is the one about the creative possible potential of a free
society,
which I think you had a memo to write about.
And the notion there is that social learning will accrue that the society at
large will have a higher learning rate than any individual within it.
And that as each of us goes about her or his,
uh,
work,
we are spewing off,
uh,
insights for others,
both when we succeed and when we fail,
when we succeed,
people will copy our ideas.
When we fail,
people will know an idea not to try.
And that over time a society actually smart up.
And if you look at the first chapter in the assignment for today in Clark,
he has,
uh,
all the factors of growth as he conceives them in a very simplified model.
And the residual,
the residual which accounts for about half the variance,
uh,
it's most natural interpretation is it is social learning.
It isn't the specific capital embodied in a given workers education or in the
factory plant and equipment with which that worker is supplied by an employer.
Uh,
but in the less tangible forms of social knowledge,
which the society is generating and high acts idea then is that over time social
learning,
uh,
makes the whole system smarter,
taken as a whole and that learning to navigate unfamiliar information,
which arguably would be something you're all doing right now,
uh,
becomes not only an advantage to the individual but to the society at large.
Well,
the most glaring omission in Clark in talking about the surge of wealth in the
West is the joint stock corporation
and the joint stock corporation goes back of course,
many centuries.
Uh,
but the kind of jaw joint stock corporation,
which has become a dominant in the world,
uh,
goes back only to about the middle of the 18 hundreds.
Um,
in the UK it's dated to the corporation act of 1862,
uh,
in the u s I think you'd probably say somewhere in the 1840 [inaudible] it
becomes important.
You can find legal traces of it much earlier and in both cases,
but it gets to be a big deal in the middle years of the 19th century.
And as we saw with the reading from Bob,
okay.
Uh,
Alfred,
Alfred Chandler,
uh,
the rise of the large scale a railroad in the u s provoked the creation of the
equity and bond markets in New York,
uh,
and the,
feverish development of joint stock corporations in virtually every field of
endeavor.
Uh,
thereafter,
uh,
these slides,
I'm going to show a series of proprietary slide constructed by Ibbotson
associates.
Ibbotson associates is named for Roger Ibbotson at the School of management
here.
Uh,
Ibbotson
yeah.
Became a filthy rich by,
uh,
being the first one to systematically,
compile,
analyze,
and sell long trend data about stocks and bonds.
Okay.
And it's only because he likes to teach that he bothers to continue.
Uh,
the timescale here is 1925.
Two more of us,
the president,
uh,
and the,
earnings of various classes of assets are a trace tier,
uh,
beginning in this case with treasury bills issued by the government and as safe
as the government,
uh,
is,
then municipal bonds,
government bonds of other kinds of corporate bonds.
So a that this would be debt taken on by a corporation and it might be,
they might be junk bonds if the corporation is a little risky and they might be
blue chip bonds if not,
and then uh,
this is the blue curve is an amalgam of stock returns.
And in every case we start with $1 in 1925 and keep investing the money.
The,
the way these charts are are generated is um,
we assume that every dollar of dividend is plowed back,
uh,
and that we don't pay any taxes.
So this would sort of be Yale that were charting you and I wouldn't quite have
the same tax privilege Gail has.
And the most striking thing there is,
what's the most striking thing about that chart?
First of all,
there is some magic in compound interest,
right?
You can just leave your money to grow.
It really does eventually do that.
But how about the blue curve versus the others?
Pretty startling.
We've got to get somebody else to yes.
Tall
there.
There seems to be rather large equity premium.
Okay.
When,
what I mean by that is that there seems to be,
uh,
excess returns if you put your money in stocks versus any of the other
categories,
treasuries,
corporate bonds.
Okay.
Um,
I mean you're obviously taking on more risk,
right?
The stocks versus the other categories,
certainly more than treasury bills.
But,
um,
you could possibly argue that the difference in risk,
uh,
it doesn't seem as great as a difference in returns over the long run.
Okay.
And,
uh,
what's the stat that the equity premium is the punchline here while shed?
And what's the standard way one might manage the risk of a portfolio?
You could diversify.
Okay.
So we wouldn't put all our money in mining stocks or in even in Apple,
um,
which is right now one of the most expensive stocks in the universe.
But the equity premium is huge.
And look here,
what happens,
this was 1925.
The depression is here,
the great crash is here.
Uh,
these people got jolted,
right?
And of course the temptation when that happens to you is to imagine that it's
going to go right to the middle of the earth and therefore to sell at this
point,
which lots and lots of people did.
And of course the effect was,
uh,
to ruin their wealth.
Let's take another set of these.
Uh,
we've,
we let inflation go unnoticed in that one.
And here we'll show inflation by the red curve.
And then
the t bills,
government bonds,
large company stocks,
small company stocks,
and you get a huge premium there.
Now the,
the back to the question of,
of the accumulation of mass affluence,
the power of large enterprise to generate a enormous wealth over long periods,
right?
This is a,
a 75,
80,
85 year period.
We're looking at,
uh,
but patient money,
patiently invested in joint stock corporations,
uh,
is a solid strategy,
for the accumulation of wealth within a given household,
uh,
or,
institutional portfolio.
Uh,
it's not anywhere near the sexiest or the fastest way,
uh,
but it is,
one of the most solid ways.
And the only conclusion I want to get out of this is that in talking about
economic takeoff and the sustained growth in mass affluence,
uh,
companies,
joint stock companies with limited liability are a big part of that.
Third and last,
uh,
with,
remember the variable here is gross domestic product per capita and part of
that,
uh,
has to do with a propensity to consume.
And in the Posner book about what went wrong with the mortgage markets,
uh,
canes,
Lord Lord chains is mentioned and Keynesian economics,
which are,
uh,
which are directed to the question of stabilizing mass demand for product,
so that the economy keeps going around and around,
uh,
is an important element.
Well,
the joint stock corporation was a,
from its birth,
really good at selling and the move,
which would be called forward integration.
We're not just going to make cigarettes,
we're going to sell cigarettes.
We're not just going to make soap.
We're going to sell soap.
We're not just going to make cars.
We're going to sell them a that forward integration.
I'm going to without comment now,
just show you a 20 slides from the middle decades of the 20th century and then
we'll stop briefly and segue to next.
Our next meeting.
Some of these are a little pernicious.
This one is not.
Uh,
the,
a repeated trope is using products to solve marital problems and the large glove
compartment on this mercury,
uh,
will solve the marital problem between these two.
Okay.
When my grandfather died and I was 17,
I inherited a mercury from him.
It lasted one year before I crashed it.
Okay.
Quiet substance.
There's a series of pall mall labs here.
They all have to do with men and women.
Women are the sales target.
There's Palmolive soap exist still.
Does anybody use it?
Ah,
that's pretty nasty
stuff,
right?
This is rouge,
not soap now.
Okay,
well you get the jest of it.
Um,
so in the consumer culture that's embodied in these and which is a powerful,
powerfully represented all around us,
right?
We live in a very consumption oriented culture.
Uh,
is,
is arguably a misleading misleadingly favorable aspect of wealth.
That is an awful lot of,
if you think about those ads and how silly
it seems with 70 years hindsight that using Palmolive soap will save your
marriage went off and gasses that it didn't save a single marriage.
Um,
that whole angle of kind of the huckster ish aspect of a capitalist society.
I can give one pause.
No,
I'd like you to come to class Wednesday having thought a little about a country
and what 5% of its GDP would amount to in dollars and if need to look that up.
You know,
you can Google it the easiest.
Google is a CIA fact book.
Uh,
but the World Bank will give you the data to the World Bank or um,
uh,
the WTO.
They're all kinds of organizations that produce these data.
Pick a country and think about 5% and think about how you would deploy the 5%,
uh,
if you wanted to maximize the expected wealth of that society over about say,
a 20 year future.
Uh,
the reading is the more policy oriented part of desoto and it should in some
ways guidance,
support.
Uh,
you're thinking,
although you surely want to think well beyond a discharges framework,
so I'll see you on Wednesday.